it has been
1856 days since the 2016 presidential
election
we are now in the second week of the
12th month of the year of our lord 2021
and still
hillary clinton is crying about losing
the 2016 election and i do not mean
crying in a figurative way
i mean she is literally tearing up
on television
reading the victory speech that she had
written
and intended to give but but never had
the chance to give
i didn't as you know write a concession
speech because even though we had a lot
of bumps those last 10 days
i still thought you know we could pull
it out so i worked on
a speech that really
was about my journey and
had had a real emphasis on my mother's
life and journey as a way of you know
making it clear that yes i would be the
first woman president but i i like
everybody uh stood on the shoulders and
lived the
lives uh and experiences of those who
came before us i dream of going up to
her
and sitting down next to her
taking her in my arms
and saying look at me
listen to me
you will survive
you will have a good family of your own
and three children
and as hard as it might be to imagine
your daughter will grow up and become
the president of the united states
[Music]
that video is and i say this without
any exaggeration
the single funniest thing i have ever
seen it is so
perfect every single
thing about it
play it again
look at me
listen to me
you will survive
you will have a good family of your own
and three children
and as hard as it might be to imagine
your daughter will grow up and become
the president of the united states
[Music]
except she won't
she won't that won't happen ever
this is so
so sad so funny and so sad this is even
worse than that time that hillary
tweeted out a picture of herself on her
birthday and it was herself as a little
girl and it said happy birthday to this
future president but she lost the
republicans beat her just like
republicans are once again beating back
leftist politicians and policies in a
way that we have not seen in years i am
really glad you like that clip i am
i i could not be i could be happier
here's how i could be happier
ring the bell
please i would appreciate it if you ring
the bell you get the notifications you
should also go to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcast you can type in the
michael show subscribe maybe leave a
five-star review if you wouldn't mind
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]